so last Friday President Obama gave his
last press conference as
commander-in-chief yeah
undeterred by his would-be successors
devastating loss to Donald Trump in the
presidential election unswayed by
Republicans complete domination of
Congress state legislatures and governor
mansions he maintained his cool and
collected self aggrandizement why not
according to Obama Obama has been a
massive success perhaps the most
hilarious moment of delusion came when
he talked about terrorism he said over
the past eight years
no foreign terrorist organization has
successfully executed in an attack on
our homeland that was directed from
overseas he then continued saying no
attack had been executed in a rainstorm
with the attacker driving a tractor with
one hand drinking a Miller High Life
with the other wearing a clown nose
to be fair Obama didn't actually say
that last part but he may as well have
in order to find a way the problem of
terrorism that has grown dramatically
worldwide on his watch he simply spoke
of terrorism is a problem of organized
groups within defined territories which
is not how terrorism actually works
terrorist groups can recruit without
formal structures that can operate as
independent cells within various
countries just three days after Obama's
statements an alleged jihadi plowed her
truck into a Christmas market in Berlin
the same day a Turkish terrorists
murdered the Russian ambassador to
Turkey these latest attacks are not
outliers in the past several years we've
seen terrorist attacks in Turkey and
Germany and Belgium Great Britain in
Canada and Australia among others this
sort of terrorism isn't relegated to
foreign countries of course here's an
incomplete list of radical Islam related
terror attacks and attempts on American
soil under Obama shootings of American
military recruiters in Little Rock
Arkansas the massacre at Fort Hood the
Boston Marathon bombing and attempted
bombing of the airport in Wichita Kansas
Hatchett attacks on New York City police
officers attempted shootings at the draw
Muhammad events in Garland Texas the
attacks had military recruiters in
Chattanooga Tennessee the massacre at
the San Bernardino inland regional
center Darrell Andrew nightclub shooting
the New York and New Jersey bombings in
the Ohio State University car attack
just to name some obama still thinks he
can cover his abysmal record with
closely drawn definitions of terrorism
which is the equivalence of Bill Clinton
saying he's been faithful to his wife
except for certain areas like sex which
is technically true so far as it goes
but you didn't go all that far Americans
know that and they reacted to Obama's
consistent lying by omission by electing
Trump a man who needs pretty much no
evidence to jump to conclusions Obama is
so careful to avoid spotting fact
patterns he simply omits inconvenient
data points
Trump is so eager to spot fact patterns
he simply includes convenient non data
points but Americans would actually
rather have from stumped conclusions
mentality that Obama's avoid conclusions
at all cost mentality Trump's mentality
may lead to mistakes but those mistakes
are less likely to cost Western lives so
Obama can hawk his faux sophistication
on terrorism as much as he wants if
Democrats want to ensure that
Republicans continue to win elections
they ought to follow his lead
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]
all righty so we are back we're back for
this shortened Christmas week sorry I
was on the road a little bit there's a
picture that's going around of me and
Ted Cruz and we are both laughing at
something I will let you guess as to
what it is that we are laughing about
but nonetheless there's a lot to get to
a lot has happened in my absence that
you leave for two days and the world is
on fire
of course when I'm here to the world's
also on fire unlike Andrew clave now I'm
out a tribute all world events to my
absence from the political scene but we
have to begin today by saying hello to
one of my advertisers texture calm so
texture this is a great service a great
app and what it allows you to do is you
pay $9.99 a month what you get in return
is access to over 200 magazines you get
200 mags so you're not paying for a
separate subscription each magazine
because the truth is you don't want to
read every article in time or every
article in Newsweek or every article in
Sports Illustrated you want to read the
ones that you want to read and texture
allows you to do that so for people who
are and reading junkies like me people
who just have to have information poured
into their brain using enormous silos
texture is that is the place for you
texture calm slash man that gets you a
14-day free trial and it is it is a
great service I mean the list of
magazines is really really long they
give you access to all of these all of
these magazines and not just one you can
check back issues you can view bonus
video content they curate articles and
magazines just for use so that it is
that you can access just the stuff you
want to see it's stuff ranging from
Sports Illustrated and Entertainment
Weekly to Vanity Fair and Rolling Stone
and Cosmo and the great thing again is
that you don't have to buy a
subscription to Cosmo you can just read
the stupid article the Cosmo posted
about the games family or you can go to
Reader's Digest and read that while
you're on the toilet textured makes sure
that you can get access to all of these
magazines wherever you are it really is
fantastic service textured comm slash
event okay so well I was gone the
Democrats decided that it would be a
great idea to double down on everything
terrible that they ever thought about
anything which is just a genius move one
day thousands of years from now people
will look back and they will see that
Americans liked Lena Dunham or at least
some Americans liked Lena Dunham for
example and they will say to themselves
why just why like why Lena why there's
no answer I mean there's a cosmic
questions that people will be asking
themselves generations from now
but the Democrats are addicted to Lena
Dunham they love Lena Dunham because
they love people who have the charisma
and the and the brains and the looks of
a russet potato but apparently the left
just a lot of toast Oh Lena Dunham it
was at the DNC as you recall they loved
her so much they put her on stage at the
DNC and here is what that looked like I
am a pro-choice feminist sexual assault
survivor with a chronic reproductive
illness Donald Trump and his body think
I should be punished for exercising my
constitutional rights his rhetoric about
women takes us back to a time when we
were meant to be beautiful and silent
meanwhile 22 years ago Hillary Clinton
declared that women's rights are human
rights
okay so elements of this election cycle
has been watching lena Dunham's
continued mental meltdown over Donald
Trump's victory
well now Lena Dunham says that she
wishes that she had had an abortion
right she says she wishes that she'd had
an abortion she said apparently she
informed her audience on her podcast
that while she's never had an abortion
personally she wishes she had so she
could do her part to reduce stigma
around the issue and she said I can say
I still haven't had an abortion but I
wish I had okay so if Democrats are
looking to win Americans probably the
best way to do that is not to trot out
at the DNC the lady who says that she
wished that she had had a baby in her
stomach just in her uterus just so that
you could murder the baby so that she
could feel the Solidarity and joy of
having murdered a baby I mean really his
pretty egregious stuff
Democrats usually have the brains to
cover up their enthusiasm about abortion
they usually have the brains to say
things like Bill Clinton safe legal and
rare or it's a tragic decision a woman
has to make right ignoring of course the
fact that if it's a tragic decision then
you shouldn't be allowed to do it right
and the whole idea of legalizing
abortion rests on the notion that it's
not a tragic decision it's the same
thing as removing Apollo but the
Democrats usually don't speak in those
lang in that sort of language because
they understand that alienates people
but Lena Dunham full-on embraces it she
says that she wishes that she'd had an
abortion so she could be part of the
Select sisterhood of women who have
engaged and and pursued the use of the
right to murder a baby in her womb if
this is the sort of thing that Democrats
think is going to win elections by all
means they should continue to
because the fact is the vast majority of
Americans don't think that abortion is a
is a pro-social thing to do they don't
think that abortion is a good thing to
do even people who are pro-choice
generally don't think abortion is a good
thing
they may think it's a necessary thing
but most of them don't think it's a good
thing because most of them still have a
basic semblance of Uncle discomfort with
abortion she actually said on this
podcast that that was one of her one of
the reasons she wishes she had had one
cuz people were talking about their
abortions and she felt uncomfortable
because deep down and lena Dunham's body
there still resides a small spark of
godly soul that says to her yeah you
should be uncomfortable with people
killing babies and she says I want to
extinguish that by presumably getting
pregnant and killing the baby she's now
come out and apologized because whenever
Democrats get caught doing stuff they
come out and apologize falsely but
that's of course what she thinks and
that's not the only way in which
Democrats have lost their minds and are
doubling down on everything radical that
they can possibly conceive of the other
thing that came out over the last couple
of days is of course this insane insane
insane video from MTV so MTV released a
video of a bunch of people who you would
never want to associate with in real
life like people who just look at them
and how smug and self-satisfied they're
and you think I would not want to be
within a hundred miles of these folks
MTV released a video of resolutions for
four white guys for 2017 they're telling
you what your resolutions should be
because there's nothing more
ideologically fascistic than telling
other people what they should aspire to
be in the coming year here's MTV
informing you remember what MTV used to
put on music videos remember that yeah
not anymore
this is what it is now it's about to be
a new year and there's a few things we
think you could do a little bit better
in 2017
first off try to recognize that America
was never great for anyone who wasn't a
white guy can we all just agree that
black lives matter isn't the opposite of
all eyes matter
okay so sorry Austin is running back and
forth to CV screen to computer it's
amusing to watch I'm gonna continue this
pattern but it's but that I love that
the first gal gets options can we agree
America was never great for anyone who
wasn't a white male no we can't agree on
that at all as a Jew with ancestors who
were Jews I can pretty much agree
America's the greatest country that God
ever created by the way for black people
living in today's America America is the
greatest country that God ever created
and even during Jim Crow America was a
much better country for black people
than the vast majority of countries
around the world which is not a case in
favor of Jim Crow god forbid but to
suggest that America was never great for
anybody except white men is just a bunch
of crap I mean how about white women by
the way white women have had a better in
America than any place else on earth I
mean America is is heaven for white
women in white women now earned more
than white men white women are going to
college at a higher rate than white men
even in the supposedly horrific terrible
horrible horrible terrible 50s women
were actually pretty happy if you look
at the pulse of female satisfaction
because they were living in a prosperous
country and what a bunch of knots and
then this woman says can we just agree
that black lives matter doesn't just
mean black lives matter all lives
mattered is not a response to black
lives matter no because the entire black
lives matter movement is predicated on
the notion that black lives are
specifically under difference assault on
other lives in the United States by
white people and that is not true
and then I do love the fact that where
they go next in the 17 video is they say
black lives matter you know it doesn't
all eyez matter is not a proper response
to black lives matter because of course
all lives matter but we're just talking
about black lives now and then the next
thing they say is that not all lives
matter black lives just matter there's
no need to overcomplicate it
also blue lives matter isn't a thing
cops ball ball with blue skin right I
mean dead they won't form blue stop
bragging about being woke stop saying
woke learn what mansplaining is and then
stop doing it oh and if you're a judge
don't prioritize the well-being of
making Austin run back and forth is
really amusing okay so don't you
whoa how about you stop using loke it's
obnoxious and no one knows what the hell
you're talking about yeah oh you're woke
woke - what did you awake did you wake
up what why are you using a passive verb
in place of an active one in any case
that I do love the the I don't use woke
also stop mansplaining to stop
mansplaining to us man's planning is the
stupidest word that anyone ever created
mansplaining
okay it's called an explanation if a man
is doing it and it is worthwhile that
does not mean that he's doing it as a
man okay men used to have a word for
women's blaming it was called nagging
okay this is routine because these
people desperately this is donald
trump's reelection ad right here and
it's fun to watch Ivy League athlete
over the woman he assaulted we all love
Beyonce and yes she's black so of course
she cares about bike issues I'm talking
to you FoxNews feel free to take Kanye
West though you guys can happen you know
what you did Kanye nobody who has black
friends says that they have black
friends it's just because you have black
friends doesn't mean you're not racist
you're gonna be racing with black
friends look guys we know nobody's
perfect but honestly you could do a
little better in 2017 some of you guys
do a great job some of you don't please
because 2016 is bad 2017 can't be worse
than this all right because this is bad
okay I'm gonna listen to the to the
black guy with the cat on his shirt
telling me about what it means to be a
better person because he's a black guy
with a cat on a shirt that's basically
what this comes down to I mean this
video comes down to it's a bunch of not
white males lecturing white males and
that's okay because they have a moral
superiority because they're not white
males here's my question what do these
people actually do does anyone know any
of these people like I don't know any of
these people I don't know them from Adam
I don't care what color they are what
their sex is doesn't matter to me do
they do decent things I mean for all I
know these people that this is a series
of axe murderers that went to San
Quentin and dragged out of prison to
lecture white males the idea that these
folks are granted some extra legitimacy
because of their color or because of
their sex well what a bunch of absolute
nonsense I also love the fact there's an
irony to the fact that you have the the
one guy saying just because you don't
say you have black friends that that
doesn't mean that you're not a racist
and then this entire video is built
around the concept that because they're
showing a bunch of black people showing
some black people and some Hispanic
people sebacean people because they're
showing various diverse people that
means they can be racist against white
people right so there's a certain irony
to that as well but again all of this is
designed all of this is designed not to
win elections it is designed to further
polarize the population they think that
demographically in the next election
cycle they're gonna have some advantages
because they think that by 2020
Millennials will represent people who
are currently Millennials will represent
40% of the voting base they think that
the Hispanic base is gonna grow they
think that they're just gonna out
demographics the rest of the United
States but it turns out that that's not
how politics works as late as two years
ago Democrats were saying we'd never win
well six months ago Democrats were
saying Republicans would never win
another presidential election in 2008
the idea was Republicans who never win
back Congress by 2010 they had people
are people they have ideas their brains
function and they're not just a set of
physical characteristics on the outside
and so you can't just suggest that white
people are bad and everybody else is
good and then hope to win elections
that's not how any of this works but
again Democrats don't know this and so
they keep doubling down on the stupid
I one of the more amusing sites over the
weekend by the way was was Bill Clinton
on Monday cast his electoral vote he was
one of the electors from New York and he
was hoping he'd be casting the winning
electoral votes for Hillary he cast his
electoral votes and he wept as he
realized that Hillary would now be
lurking around Chappaquiddick or
Chappaqua some more and he'd have to
find a different outhouse to stash his
mistress yeah but I've never cast about
I was prouder of
you know I watched her work for two
years I watched her battle through that
bogus email deals be vindicated the
engine secretary Powell's book and out
she fought through that she fought
through everything and she prevailed
against at all but you know at the end
we had to rush into me and the FBI do we
she couldn't prevail against that she
did everything experts the finest vote
counter in america is nate silver he
told you what cost of the election okay
and then bill clinton by the way said
that trump only knows how to win angry
white males that was as those a
summation of the election bill should
know since that was a large part of his
base in 1992 and 1996 where the same
dispossessed white folks that voted for
Trump voted for Bo Clinton in 1992 and
1996 again all of this stuff is just
alienating the same voters they just
lost there's no purpose to it other than
they think that the demographics are
going to save them demographics don't
save you once you decide to blow off
half the population more than half the
population okay so now we gotta say
hello before we go any further and we
have some pretty stunning video coming
up and a lot more to talk about
including Trump's infrastructure plans
and the and the the continued fallout
from from what's happening over in
Turkey and Russia but first we have to
say hello to our advertisers over at sea
so so see SOCOM is the place for comedy
if you are interested in in watching
comedy if you're a comedy addict then
see SOCOM is for you use the promo code
bending a tube three months they have
all of the backlogged episodes of
British comedies like the office in the
entire Monty Python catalog they have
all of the backlog of SNL and The
Tonight Show Starring Fallon and and
they have classics like 30 rock and
Parks and Rec they even have Saved by
the Bell so if you're really into comedy
see so is the place to be for comedy and
it's 399 it's 399 a month so it's
SuperDuper cheap and you get all the
comedy that you can that you could ever
want out of this it's definitely a
relief at the end of the day because our
politics has become very serious of late
and this is definitely a relief they
produce a bunch of their own series as
well by the way the bunch of original
series some of which are really really
funny they have they have some reality
and thick reality shows that are really
funny see SOCOM is the place to be 399 a
month my wife and I really really enjoy
it
so see so calm use that promo code bed
and get two months for free okay so
again Democrats are intent on losing
2020 the same way they lost 2016 and so
during the electoral college vote on
Monday you can see how the protesters
reacted to Wisconsin electors voting for
Donald Trump go to Warren that is a
crazy lady before the sava protesters
one of the protesters has a ball the
sense of Donald J Trump yeah that way
too way to really draw in those voters
and and really convince people that they
were wrong screaming at the electors
whose job it is to just confirm the vote
and then there's this video which has
been making the rounds this apparently
is a trump supporter being beaten and
dragged out of his car this is going
around a couple of weeks ago apparently
he's okay but this this video has been
going around as well and then there is
this guy being dragged alongside the car
oh yeah that is awful so yeah that kind
of stuff is definitely gonna help win
Democrats back there they're voting base
that they lost in this particular
election cycle all so they can continue
to Foskey Thole berman who has
completely lost what was left of his
tiny mind what was not occupied by his
by his kittens and his agriculture
degree from Cornell
he's lost what was left of it and and
now he is saying the best way to resist
Trump is to never say president Trump
never say it not using one word can be
just as forceful as perpetually use
another never address Trump as president
he is Trump just Trump never president
the title of president that we must
protect for a happier and more honest
time resistance means refusal resist
peace he's been reduced to saying single
words at a time because he can't speak
in phrases anymore as his brain breaks
down in front if you think that
Republicans are going to be devastated
because Keith Olbermann doesn't call him
president Trump yeah right I also
remember don't you remember when all the
Democrats were saying that if you called
Obama Obama and not President Obama it
was racist that was the thing like very
early on in his presidency if he called
him Barack Hussein Obama fused his
middle name that was racist and if he
used his last name only that was racist
you had to call him President Barack
Obama or President Obama but you can do
it against Trump and that is a way to
resist peace I'm inside a box no one
knows how to get out it's amazing
and then he Keith Oldman may in fact be
the first actual live speaking mime he's
not actually a silent man he actually
speaks and finally you have Robert Reich
she's the former secretary of a labor
under under Bill Clinton and he has a
proposal to stop Donald Trump and here
it is a lot of people are analyzing
what's going right on right now not a
lot are doing what you did and actually
talking about a resistance agenda that
talks about getting Democrats in
Congress and across the country to
pledge to oppose the Trump agenda to
boycotting all Trump products real
estate hotels resorts everything around
the world can you go through what you're
suggesting
yes Amy generally I think we do have to
regard this as not a normal presidency
you know some people say oh well it's
just a we've had conservative pompous
narcissistic presidents before this is
this is not normal this is really
dangerous and we have to resist we have
to have a peaceful
they keep doing this we have to resist
okay your resistance is just tears that
Donald Trump will swing at night the
idea that your boycott is gonna do
anything to the Trump Organization is
absolutely nonsense he now has the
biggest brand on planet Earth he's the
President of the United States so Robert
Righteous boycott means nothing also
that you keep hearing Democrats use
these sorts of words like we cannot
normalize Trump we can't just say it's
the new normal we can't normalize him
it's not up to you it's not up to he's
gonna do it he's gonna do and people are
either gonna like it or they ain't gonna
like it
but you don't get to decide what's
normal you guys decided that Barack
Obama's behavior as president was normal
you decided that Bill Clinton's behavior
as president was normal you don't get to
decide what's normal and what's not I
mean in your world it is not normal for
a Christian Baker to be able to not bake
a cake for a same-sex wedding but it is
normal for a nine year old boy to be a
nine year old girl so you definitely do
not get to define normal for me you
definitely not get to define normal I'm
fine with the idea that Trump does
things that are abnormal but Robert Ryan
company do not get to decide what is
abnormal and what should be normalized
and what should not because they are so
far beyond the pale of what is what is
even reasonable that to have them draw
the outer limit of normal and put Trump
beyond that is just ridiculous okay so
that brings us the end of our live
broadcast at fit at Facebook but you can
go over to daily wire and you can check
out the the rest of the show live daily
Wired icon become a subscriber $8 a
month I think that the deal is still on
if you get an annual subscription you
get a free copy free signed copy of my
book true allegiance just in time for
the Christmas holiday and you're going
to want to be a part of it we got a
bunch of new stuff coming out next year
we've got a store that's coming out
we've got a lot of big things plans for
next year for our for our members
particularly become a member at daily
wire calm or you can listen later at
iTunes and SoundCloud and in view later
YouTube we are the the largest
conservative podcast in America
[Music]
you